Japan is one of the few developed countries...
...where the #MeToo movement has yet to take hold.
Women play a key role in the world's third biggest economy,...
...but they must contend with a large gender pay gap.
In addition, women occupy only about 10% of senior positions...
...in the public and private sectors.
Political representation is poor.
Only three members of the current 20-member cabinet are women.
Just five of the 48 councilors here are women.
One of them, the independent council of Yuka Ogata,...
...is shaking up Kumamoto's male-dominated political establishment.
In 2017, Ogata caused a stir...
...when she took her newborn son into the assembly chamber.
She'd intended to highlight the lack of support for working mothers,...
...but her gesture angered her male colleagues...
...and she was ordered to leave the chamber.
I felt I have all the right to be in the chamber.
Nobody has the right to expel me because I'm representing people.
So I was really trying to hold my ground...
...no matter how many times they tell me to leave with my baby.
Two years have passed since Ogata's protest,...
...but the local assembly has still not opened...
...child care facilities on its premises.
That said, Ogata has become the most visible champion...
...of women's rights in the city.